mme labrosse cox
on démarre en plein coeur de la touraine
avec rémy camus notre aventurier de
l'extrême
toujours à la recherche de nouvelles
sensations il a rendez vous avec une
équipe de marcheurs pas comme les autres
aujourd'hui je vous embarque dans le
parc régional de touraine
nous allons rencontrer david et sandrine
qui vont nous faire découvrir quelque
chose d'assez atypique la cani rando
salut bonjour et mes amis a bien chanté
salut sandrine fait lui je te présente
emilie enchanté va être notre guide
nature aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'elle
va nous faire découvrir la partie nature
la partie patrimoine ça c'est notre
belle région et je vais présenter aussi
à dire les époques on a d'autres
partenaires après qui sont là qui sont
impatients à ce que fait présente avec
areva et cet article ils sont
tranquilles pour l'instant on agit à ron
way jaguar et d'arrières mystique cas
d'accord un patient bientôt bientôt
beatles
[Musique]
david sandrine et leurs compagnons à
quatre pattes propose deux styles deux
randonnées des sorties en kart tracté
par un attelage de 12 chiens ou des
balades à pied comme aujourd'hui
[Musique]
bien sûr ton fessier faut pas 40 sur
terrain si je suis d'accord pour qu'on
binôme ça marche je peux faire équipe et
donc tu vois le harnais je les ai
passées on commence par faire passer la
tête
shawa on est partis en vue que tu
connais déjà
ça m'arrange tu sais exactement comment
ça devrait se passer et oui je savais et
ensuite je t'en prie
merci demande l'autre c'est bien on
embauche tu as pour venir travailler
avec nous génial au démarrage les chiens
ils vont vous tester pour voir à quelle
vitesse vous allez le chien va prendre
ce qu'on lui donne à vous accélérez le
chien va accélérer ou le ralenti c'est
marcher normalement
le chien au bout de quelques mètres où
vous allez voir il s'habituera voilà
pour les ordres c'est pas compliqué
cette droite gauche avec le nom du chien
jawa droite jawa gauche ça marche ce que
je trouve intéressant c'est du coup moi
ce n'est pas mon chien je suis pas le
maître de ce chien imam écoutée même si
je vous donne 7 euros oui parce que
c'est ton partenaire vous allez créer
une petite fusion entre vous c'est ça
qui va faire qu'il va tu écoutais mais
faut être ferme et autoritaire d'accord
du coup c'est un dressage qui est
particulier c'est une éducation mais
sachez que des très ferme très dur
l'éducation tout et au jura dès que tu
vas voir pour repartir l'activité sur un
jeu c'est une envie
est-ce que vous avez compris les
consignes oui à la partie allez bon
centre ok c'est parti ce matin pour 10
km de marche